[Applause]
[Music]
it was a teenage wedding in the old
folks wish somewhere you could see the
PFD truly loved the madam wasn't and now
the young and my dad come on the chapel
Bell say let me say they are folks goes
to show you never can tell
no no they furnish Stafford upon them
with a to say the coolest friend TV
dinners a ginger
[Music]
well Santa Fe's goes to show you never
can tell you never can tell they buy
souped-up Jimmy was a cherry way 53 they
drove it down to New Orleans to
celebrate the anniversary mom it was
there where PA was wedded to the lovely
madam were there said I'm supposed to
show you never can tell
no no you never can tell
you never can tell
you never can tell never no no you never
can tell
thank you I recently had the tremendous
opportunity of searching for gold in the
vast mine of songs released by Chess
Records
chicago-based label that was really very
active in the 50s and 60s in the US and
and that music spread all over the world
and the songs that I'm seeing tonight
are from an album that I just put out
called playing chess that pays homage to
those songs and these guys were really
you know the innovators of rock and roll
and soul and R&B as we as we now know it
[Applause]
[Music]
over the mountain across the sea there's
a guy waiting she's waiting for me
[Music]
over the river beyond over the mountain
[Applause]
[Music]
tell everybody please kill the we to lay
my weight me
[Music]
for me Oh mystery let's see so time the
mountain
[Music]
for me
and over the mountain
[Music]
oh let's see
me
[Music]
she way mommy
Oh
a challenge trying to figure out a way
to you know pay homage to these
beautiful songs without trying to even
attempt some kind of Carbon Copy I mean
you can't do Chuck Berry better than
Chuck or fontelle a bass
better than fun tell us so we had to
figure out a way to to approach these
songs so that we could you know so I
could infuse some of my own style into
them and so one of the ways we did that
was sort of stripping away a lot of what
were very big productions and I think
this next song is a good example of that
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
please baby
[Music]
[Applause]